we all think if we were rich we'd be
happy
but also we know we might not and then a
lot of people who are rich are not happy
[Music]
what did we say was the ultimate purpose
of human life according to arizona
happiness happiness and we haven't quite
said what that is
so there's a bunch of claims about what
makes happiness
they're famous claims well
pleasure pleasure pleasure yeah so
wealth is obvious isn't it
i don't know if you know the saturday
night live philosopher jack candy but
he's very profound
and one of his aphorisms is uh
it's easy wanting other people's money
that's what i like about it
[Laughter]
and we all think don't we if we were
rich
we'd be happy but also by the way in our
heart of hearts
we know we might not and that a lot of
people who are rich are not happy
and what else did you name uh pleasure
pleasure
pleasure is good we like it can you
think is it is it happiness what does
aristotle say about that
he said it's the life of fatted cattle
if you live only for that and only in
the common sense meaning
of that it wouldn't be good for us if we
just pursued that
exclusively and we all know something
aristotle points out powerfully in this
book
we all know that if you just went after
that stuff
fully that among the things that would
happen is it wouldn't be very pleasant
[Music]
see i don't i don't think alcoholics
take a lot of pleasure and alcohol
i think in fact it's a plague upon them
and uh i think that a lot of things are
like that
so pleasure won't do and wealth won't do
what else one
honor honor now what about honor what's
honor
good regard from others is that the same
thing as happiness being honorable
no why not he says that the people who
or people who want to be honored in the
political life want to be honored by
people who are virtuous so what their
what their their aim is not just
honor but it's honor from something they
value more than just honor in itself uh
gil suggested a
complication in honor
there'd always be the temptation
to value the honor
as much or more than the
quality that gives rise to it
what would you say uh one is there a
difference in dignity
between those first two things pleasure
and wealth and the claims of honor
they have some good in them but pleasure
is not inherently bad
and the same thing for wealth there is a
place for wealth as well
and so i think the same is for all three
of them um
yeah nobody's claiming here that it
wouldn't be better to be rich
it just isn't enough right
and that's true of everything else now
we'll go to page 10
okay there's a paragraph at the bottom
says but perhaps to say
somebody read that but perhaps to say
that the highest good is happiness is
obviously something
undisputed while it still begs to be
said in a more clear and distinct way
what happiness
is now this might come about readily if
one were to grasp the work of a human
being
grasp the work of the human being
what does a human being do okay
but presumably it makes no small
difference whether one supposes the
highest good to consist in possession
or in use that is in an actively
maintained condition
or any way of being at work and what
active condition means
is you have gone through the process of
engraving on your soul
the possession of these virtues and now
they are solid in you
and you are manifesting them
they radiate from you and what being at
work means is
when the virtues are actually engaged
and so the epitome of a human experience
is this active condition or habit of
being
at work or expressing character when the
human being is fully engaged
one of the reasons we like sport there's
a basketball game tonight i think
and basketball is good because you can
see them
both the girls and the boys and they're
you're close to them
and you see them under strain and you
see
a long practiced capacity and active
condition
fully at work and that's what we like
about sports we like to see that
and that's because a human being is
excelling at something
what the human being is made for is
those moments
when its qualities are fully engaged
happiness is ultimately an activity of
the soul
that is excellent in all of the ways
that the human being
acts and also all of the ways that the
human being
thinks and if you can
be good at all of those things
you will certainly have a wide measure
of happiness
and to the extent that you're not good
in that way
your happiness will be compromised and
aristotle presents that
as just a fact inescapable
i am larry iron president of hillsdale
college you will find if you look at our
online courses that they cover the whole
range
of human learning all the high and
fundamental things
everyone needs to know they are free
because we have always wished
to provide sound learning to anyone who
wishes to have it